for a while I had to take the earpads
out of my helmet to get my helmet on and
they would have to clip them in once I
had my helmet on Louie
shorten week where he we're back
it's the bonfire Comedy Central radio
sirius XM 95 I'm Dan Soder that just
slice of delight is big Jay oakerson are
you saying that why you watch me dive
into our now weekly studio Munchkins in
studio Munchkins and we're not talking
about cruel terms for little people
we're talking about tiny donuts little
doughnut holes little donut holes are
a good I go buy an iced coffee
and Jay and I have fallen into the
tradition of buying a box of munchkins
but now we know the 25:1 not the Finnish
crap yeah the 50 was just was a lot that
was painful hi eight five dental it's
worth as Munchkin here's the thing I
probably eight yeah I was gonna say all
the jelly-filled I'm pretty proud of
myself for getting all the jelly filled
out of the out of the 50 box
you nailed it it said walking into the
building though I'm carrying a little
briefcase like I'm a child going to
visit his dad at work like oh look Dan's
got a little briefcase of don't lose
this one had a little hint of gel you
know hmm
what'd you say this one - as quickly as
the money - the part you think you think
can click the box and found all the
jellies I did on the 50 I don't think
this one you bought this box on the
jelly King doughnut of the bonfire let
it be known I'll state my dominance in
the jelly donut world I wish you try to
grab oh dude absurd my power
watch what happens I will strike you
down like Lewinsky I murdered him that's
why he's not here today
he took a jelly doughnut what's the cake
one it's unbelievable it's unbelievable
this whole box is great just you know
what they're not giving us money just go
buy a Dunkin Donuts box against emotions
and come back and remember what you love
is about munchkins yeah there is not
just Cub Scout parties of your sad mom's
anymore yeah this isn't a a meetings
where they're trying to spruce things up
on a Tuesday just in an enjoyable moment
your life
buy some lunch get a box of munchkins
pretty good get at Enzo bar
for yourself just damn Tanner who cares
no one's watching you live your life
realistically even I didn't I don't
think I had ten munchkins or out of the
50 bucks for sure but that said I
probably did eat you know two donuts
worth of munchkin you could easily do
that well you know you just keep going
if you played a munchkin in half I'll
just fight you
oh yeah I mean what about if you do it
in a shark way which Jacob can respect
would you bite then a toss back like a
bite like a t-rex
I tear at it get it bites I'm counting
okay cool Arizona has one bite
DJ Lewinsky murdered he is in Boston
Massachusetts Boston I see the New York
Mets out again did we talk about not
letting him in the building oh
there he is again
oh my god there's two of them oh
there's two they don't die they multiply
it's the prestige Oh like spy versus spy
but the same person uh-huh uh-oh you
were imprisoned yeah if he has everyone
DJ Jacob patate running the board's
chickie Jake Oh dry Jake oh yeah all
y'all about Jacob he's all eye contact
while he plays a tune I'm doing what I'm
doing
Lou's humming along to some old wino
yeah live a couple times done too many
drugs every time I've seen Pearl Jam
never seen pearl there was any good show
out of Pearl Jam all my fault
really every time you did not enjoy both
I won no you ended up enjoying couple
songs
no I'm talking about a whole show oh I
didn't even know that I concert happened
like mushrooms
that was your candy do whatever they
call it yeah I was nipple slip and you
were fluid or I was cloud
sucking
it was terrible they kicked on like the
main like that you know the big lights
or whatever when they tell everyone to
go home and I was like things started
sucking on his candy bracelets like ours
like let's get out of here I was like
yeah need to get out of here no we were
so good out here the great tree wants to
talk to us yeah dude I was is
like you can hear light when you're on
when you're that up like it was
like the light was loud it was like
girls like sorry to leave so yeah I've
never enjoyed a Pearl Jam show but again
all my fault
take her too many drugs I'm idiot next
time I'm just gonna see them a little
stoned like a reasonable man in his
mid-30s I was just at uh this weekend
where you were in I did Governors right
no more Long Island a lot of camp is out
at a great time
well good food yeah it was actually fun
had a really good time and it's always
fun to sleep in your own bed
yeah there's you chose I came home
Saturday night after province Providence
was great
yeah I love Providence falcone came out
Hey oh gee camper weddings coming up
getting married the DJ Lou what's key is
going do we don't know yeah Christine
just said that like a mom that's mad at
a family member but you don't know why
sure I know I I don't know that's what
blue does what Lou wants to do and I'll
have to be okay with that I guess that's
just gonna be a Lou Witzke decision when
Lou Witzke decides to make it but if you
want to know what Lou Witzke blue Witzke
do you want another munchkin with that
would that ease the tension in the room
another munchkin okay I'll pass it over
the briefcase thank god someone wore
drawstring pants today
whoa dude do not knock her when you're
but everyone's on T mangyans I go why
are you wearing warm-ups like you're
about to play in the NBA but I'm
juggling these things into my face yeah
you're going to Philly this Thursday
yeah oh we have to open the
walls to get you a studio hey my
600-pound life nobody's gonna want you
yeah you're gross looking at your
friends so me and Dan will come over on
weekends and wash you with rags on
sticks but still I will only do it for
the end
grand pictures oh my god what I should
smell like in your folds now gross you
just leave me munch on that you just
assaulted that munchkin what if he was
just chewing it up and he spits in the
Christine get the taste
baby bird it wear black Lou comes in and
eats it out of Jacob's Well like a hawk
yeah like I'm going for the nip one of
my favorite Will Ferrell sketches oh the
chewed up food is it it's so gross on
it's just really funny where me I can't
believe they did it that's crazy that's
what makes me laugh so hard is that they
actually did it you can't fake
that it's so gross so gross so gross
and it's not they're not a real fit I
mean I don't know if he knows about
sketch comedy not a real family way what
they're not a real family
normal lexicon now the Chris Farley what
from the decaf commercial yeah we'll
post it at the bonfire SXM on Twitter
Instagram what's going to the paltrow no
that's not it that's I work it this is
with Chris Kattan is it well Farrell um
it's Annie McDowell is that the right
name of her Andie MacDowell
no julianna margulies is that who it is
think so
Andie McDowell's a person right yeah
she's a human being for sure
I mean Andie MacDowell could be it's
probably multiple human beings but I
mean the actress what about Bob right
yeah Groundhogs Day Groundhogs Day yeah
that's not her it's the girl you said it
looks like it's always winter on her
nose a shiny red nose yeah are you are
you always cold miss she's like no I'm
very I'm actually feeling quite family
guys so good at taking celebrities you
don't think of going at so much and
going at them just jokes like but they
had one cutaway like well fine we'll get
a shot big enough or you know a frame
big enough in the shot to get Penelope
Cruz's head the whole weight or Minnie
drivers head the whole way yeah and
you're like yeah she's a giant yeah you
look yeah there's a big ass
yeah has a guy with a big head it felt
kind of nice to land into the same field
where everyone with big heads goes hey
something's a friend right now yeah
don't you understand this I know what
you're saying about the circumference
wise and the whole hat thing with your
head
we're size eight just got a new Niners
head gonna haul bestest oh no team in
the NFL size eight a big hat yeah
that said proportionately about your
tall your broad it doesn't give a big
head
that is and I have all these problems
too you are carrying over a child
insecurity because when you were younger
match up you were a popsicle yeah I mean
I was a bobble I mean you know what it
called the like one of those big
lollipop said someone skips and licks
yeah Longstocking well yeah I was a
lollipop guild yeah everyone passing
through scuse my giant lollipop scuse me
don't look at my bloomers I'm wearing
bloomers
I'm just looking a lollipop wearing
bloomers are through the far as I'm in
my pajamas with a but flower my giant
lollipop yeah baby really is I mean
we're all like that as adults you always
carry over the thing it is one of those
things where yeah of course you carry
with it because I was called big head
middle school whatever affects you in
middle school will affect you as an
adult
yeah but it's true for sure because when
you were younger yeah it looked crazy
your body was growing into it but it
really was like a thing hello George
first my head yeah instead of like me I
developed very young which got me a lot
of male attention sure sure I had I
don't know if I was ready for it that is
a large head and I honestly didn't know
how to deal with it I was getting a lot
of whistles a lot of I mean I'm just a
kid I remember playing the Pop Warner
football and having to buy a helmet it
played again sports and you're over
sexualized by the guy who worked there
he me
is you need a jock yeah he's like what
do you mean cuz what do I mean I mean
let me show you yeah okay alright here
we put my lollipop down let's stick to
the leather band I pop now yeah like a
plastic plate damn
how big is what's the biggest helmet you
have do you think I wonder he's like I
think we my special order a helmet and I
was like this 11 lik I was 11 years old
I was like wait for a child you have to
a special order
buddy when I joined basketball leagues
yeah and they just you know everyone
grab a shirt mm-hmm and I would just
grab the same shirt that they're giving
me the same size as a kid who's 6 foot 7
yeah and like 160 pounds yeah you know I
mean so pull down like a like squeezing
a tube of tooth no I was gonna burn a
sausage that no one's little hole in no
so you're just like all beefed up and
it's just something that we try to
stretch them out and do we make him
sleeveless shirt somewhere another
sleeve shoulder that was longer yeah you
weren't long enough yeah and then when I
played on the comics league years and
years ago Talent no he's like Boston
Comedy Club comics yeah
they did the same thing everybody
grabbed his shirt and I cut mine this is
so embarrassing
to have had have to do I cut it yeah the
first night I had to just play in it
yeah like looking ridiculous and then I
went home and cut it so much up to make
it work that I ended up cutting it
straight down the sleeves so just like
down the sides we're just hung over your
head and what you can't do when you run
it's gonna flap up and everything so
yeah I had the safety pin it to the
shirt I wore underneath oh man
it looked insane it look like I was
wearing a runner's number in a marathon
it's great what more did you do it up
here it up here
wake up here and down here no I put it
over my head yeah like they'll the neck
hole was still there yeah just picture a
sleeveless shirt with like where the
armpit is just cut straight down got it
so it was like a you know a poncho am I
wrong that back in Sydney on slinger
yeah you said a
here he comes he just throw down thank
God
yeah damn when am I wrong or when like I
remember in city leagues when you're a
younger the larger the kid you were the
higher the number you had to take so it
was always like the kids in like the 98
yeah and they're like I wanted like a 12
it was a too small I was like I had to
wear like a 34 like what's my number
coach 300 yeah I'm just saying god I've
never seen a jersey he's got three
numbers on him before yes yeah I know
it's special for you when we played ayl
football that's when I played in Aurora
it was like a raw East League it was
patch League for football which I know a
lot of guys are no hard I don't
know I was the only football league
around hatch league if you wait a
certain amount you had to have a patch
on your Jersey which meant you had to
play offensive line you couldn't play a
skilled position and if you were a
double patch if you're a real fat
yeah there'd be a double patch which
means you could only play Center or
guard you weren't allowed to play tackle
they couldn't hit anybody you were huge
they're basically like doing it for the
brains of like the giant headed kids
like me with no bodies they're like yeah
this fat kids just gonna do not you
too much by two pads great being the
fact that you have a set position on a
lot of sports yeah there did patch
League anything but like I was
neighborhood games in football just
pretty obviously quarterback kind of a
little bit but more than that even just
like you know tight end ish things yeah
or you couldn't be a tight end or or
your short distance running backs tough
but there was no point in me playing
like deep coverage or anything I'll get
burnt immediately yeah there's so so
many flaws in my game and a basketball
the same thing they like four or five
was never the fastest but I was always
just down low a coach ever believed in
you put you at three on basketball no no
out I only play the game that
most ever play was like rec league was
where we had coaches and stuff yeah I
want a championship though really our
team or uh our little league football
team was so bad we were one in twenty
three used to a bit about it we lost to
a team hundred sixteen to zero like oh
yeah anyway they put skinny kids on the
other line and these double patch kids
were eating our lunch
as I move out of the way like why do you
think tall is good for the line coach
sheets what an idiot he was like your I
was like eyes at one strike again sheets
nation that is one strike you know what
I'll count it that's distracting against
sheet nation as my dad I haven't had a
pepperoni roll since the rather forget I
called my dad at his bar at the bowling
alley to be like you I'm starting
football and cuz he was at work and my
grandma's like your dad's at work but
it's like during the day call him he'll
be there and I called him and he was
like telling me about it was a Saturday
and he's like you got practice this
afternoon I was like hey he's like tell
the coach you want to play tight end
you're tall and skinny and you can catch
he's like tell the coach you wanna play
ten and like make sure you tell him that
I was like you got it and you know it
was like the 49ers so he's like like
Brett I was like like Brent Jones he's
like yeah you're gonna be like Brent
just go there and so I went in the guy
this coach that had never
coached before he's like oh no I was
like um I wanted to play quarterback or
tight end he's like well we got our
quarterback you're not a tight end
you're more of a center I mean I was
like what I'm the tallest one of the
chute all's kids on the team I should
get me in a three-point stance I'm gonna
topple over man yeah
I'm a baby deer this is crazy I did not
know how to support the man I play I go
for like I guess I'm going over serious
you better not step that bugs I'm
somersault let me do a tumble song or
roll kick that nose tackle go blue 42
call it call it call it call my butts is
going higher there you call it it's
happening double sauce double salt Oh
God yeah it did and then we just got
like all these fat kids would just like
push your head just leading you into a
large play yeah are you bringing up the
thing Christine you find the American
dad I never think Roger it was he's like
he's like all right I got it
yep now I'm going over was every
Saturday with my mom and her boyfriend
just drinking a thermos full of rum and
coke why should they just get
homo I'm not as real good I guess no I
don't worry I'm not as real I don't
believe in sports on dry land I'll be
any of these queers in a pool he
goes shave him down throw him in the
pool so you get there first
yeah man it was rough that coach
and then the next year we had this like
cool old black dude was our coach and I
was like hey I want to play tiny and
he's like yeah what were you playing and
it was like Center he goes god dammit
got a whole team and he's like you guys
are awful his his nephew Hakeem was our
running back awesome breaks his arm in
the first scrimmage of the season we go
oh it's Hakeem was awesome and
he breaks his arms like keeps out the
seasoning like god damn it we just got
lit look it was just bad but we got
lit coach scar was so awesome his old
black dude named Oscar he's like man and
he's report centering us oh god demon is
trying to recorrect everything oh man
that was brutal I'm having a bad coach
doesn't know anything about the game at
all he goes Dan what do you play on the
team because he told me I play goblin
yeah I play go get her I don't think he
knows what defense is yeah ball smacky
downey guy said he was just like he
looked like the perfect football coach
he was like a big fat dude with
monstrous calves yeah and he wore like
glasses in a hat really well at the same
time and his pants zipped
but then hooked nice truck yes they did
he had those gray jims the coach
shorts course dude and they all do yeah
any and they make those in every side he
was the nicest guy in the world now I'm
realizing he was like 28 and just didn't
know football I'm Stern I think he may
have molested me I think he had all this
each other okay yeah he just we
just that was when we lost 160 and 0 I
was like I don't think your coach knows
what he's doing you're like yeah we got
lit up yeah those shorts from Dazed and
Confused those are the exact ones you
wore yeah he would just be like oh yeah
he was huge - he's a big dude you'd
think the guy was that uh the
guy was wearing those pants that yelled
at me if I don't get the ladder my ass
he's gonna bite it out
all right yeah that's my quick shooting
an injury in left I told you about when
we were at football camp in high school
and we had this guy that used to play
football in our high school comeback as
a coach and he was like an assistant
coach or whatever and we were playing at
this football camp in Kearney Nebraska
and he got hammered with all the coaches
and showed up for the morning session
still hammered and he was like trying to
motivate us but it was just severely
inappropriate he's like if you guys
don't love it if this ain't making
your dick hard I don't know what's wrong
with you and everyone's like what like
the whole time he had like chew in his
mouth he's like if your guys's Dick's
aren't rock hard right now to go out
play these guys like yeah no it's a
different emotion I think we're more
angry and ready to go I don't think we
want to these guys it was a really
weird you would look Nate here on top of
him you want him looking up you let him
know let's stare right in your eyes
bitch warning y'all both one he goes oh
I bet you guys just looking over there
one kiss their sweaty necks under those
helmets just rubbing them comes together
you and your ball hands get between the
holes
[Music]
you